avec nous ce soir Jean Boivin ancien
cheminée
sous gouverneur à la Banque du Canada
maintenant directeur général de Black
Rock
des banques du système Swift de
l'interdiction des transactions avec la
banque centrale russe jusqu'à quel point
la Russie est et sera ébranlée par ses
sanctions
donc on est on se posait la question
jusqu'à la semaine dernière est-ce que
l'extension va être suffisante pour être
vraiment avoir un impact dissuasif et
leur présentement ce qui était mis en
place au cours des derniers jours et
maintenant qu'il va être mis en
application
et en fait je pense la meilleure façon
de caractériser c'est qu'on est en train
de créer une crise financière domestique
en Russie à travers ses sanctions-là qui
ont été mises en place l'élément le plus
important et qui était un peu une
surprise c'est le fait que la banque
centrale est le même été mis dans le
Gironde de ces sanctions-là ce qui fait
en sorte que les réserves de la Banque
centrale qui sont situés à l'extérieur
de la Russie et on parle à peu près de
la moitié de ses réserves 300 milliards
sont sont en fait maintenant
effectivement je l'ai et donc ça ça va
empêcher la Russie être en mesure de
d'essayer de protéger son économie
d'empêcher d'évaluation du Rhône et
comme on l'a vu vous l'avez mentionné
plutôt 30 % d'évaluation ils sont un peu
ouais donc c'est effectivement ce que
l'effet l'effet ultime c'est qu'on est
mis en place les éléments qui sont qui
gèle le système financier qui empêche le
fonctionnement normal qui va amener une
baisse des prix des actifs à
draconiennes et en fait un tel point qui
ont été pris pour fermer les échanges
aujourd'hui et pour écouter
effectivement les sanctions ont eu cet
effet là et ce qui m'ont ce qui monte en
puissance
l'impact donc est déjà grave ou le sera
en Russie cela dit est-ce qu'il le sera
à l'extérieur de la Russie faut-il
s'attendre à des conséquences
économiques financières énergétique
importante pour l'Europe et pour le
reste du monde
dans un terme de de de canaux de
transmission purement financier je pense
que c'est toujours difficile parce que
des effets domino on a appris après 2008
que on a envisageait pas qu'il faut
qu'ils peuvent se produire ceci dit à ce
statut l'exposition des banques
particulièrement européenne sont les
plus impliqués et quand même limité on
parle de moins de 5 % pour les dollars
de leur profit qui vient des actifs
russes donc c'est fait illimité même si
on apprenait qu'il y avait des effets de
dominos plus importants je pense la le
point le plus important c'est que les
banques centrales des économies
développées ont les moyens la capacité
de de répondre et d'empêcher que ça que
ça se traduise en effet de crise plus
importante donc je pense qu'on a les
moyens pour mitiger les impacts avec
toutes les innovation qui a été faite
avec la crise de covid et en 2008 on est
équipé on a un coffre à outils
donc on pourrait contenir l'impact sur
les finances internationales est-ce
qu'on peut contenir un impact économique
est-ce que ça peut ralentir la
croissance économique mondiale
c'est pas tellement à travers les
exportations parce que les exportations
sont toutes de la rue en général et
quand même limité ça ça peut être un
grand contraire qu'il faudra gérer mais
c'est pas ça le plus important le plus
important c'est c'est la choc pétrolier
que ça induit hausse des prix d'énergie
très très important qu'on a vu depuis le
début de la crise et ça ça se rajoute ta
dépression inflationniste qui était la
la crainte qui était déjà dans l'esprit
des marchés jusqu'à jusqu'à
déclenchement de la des conflits en
Ukraine et là on peut voir ça simplifier
donc ça c'est je pense c'est l'effet les
femmes économiques le plus important à
étudier à garder un œil
la même coupe d'application d'abord le
pouvoir d'achat ça va faire quel
portefeuille des consommateurs donc ça
ça peut créer un certain ralentissement
de l'autre côté je pense que ça va ça va
ça
nécessité que les banques centrales
continuent avec leur projet de
normaliser leur politique monétaire donc
l'inflation encore plus importantes les
pousser dans cette direction-là par
contre et ça va être plus difficile pour
les banques centrales d'aller au-delà de
la normalisation et de vraiment
resserrer la petite monétaire pour
essayer de
combattre l'inflation parce que le choc
sur la croissance va être plus présent
et donc les mains sont-elles font face à
une donne plus compliqué après le choc
en Ukraine qu'est-ce qu'on avait il y a
2 semaines donc on peut on savait qu'on
allait augmenter les taux en 2022 on
parlait depuis quelques temps d'une
accélération des hausse de taux
d'intérêt en 20223 là on vient de
retirer un peu le pied de la [ __ ] vous
pensez
ah non pas c'est déjà que les
anticipations de resserrement monétaire
était excessif
on est passé l'automne dernier à presque
aucune hausse avant la fin 2023 et
soudainement les marchés antisper 7 7
pose de tout en 2000 en 2022 qu'on
pensait qu'il était un peu réaliste donc
ça je pense avant de repousser dans une
zone plus raisonnable de je sais pas moi
aux États-Unis 3 4 4 ou 5 oh cette année
donc je pense que c'est déjà ça va ça va
se poursuivre mais pas beaucoup de la
dette ça et en Europe je pense ça risque
de calmer les anticipations pour une
hausse des taux en 2022 ce qui était
plus ou moins établi avant avant la
crise en
Ukraine très intéressant merci de cette
analyse Jean Boivin merci beaucoup
avec plaisir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI